we
are required to take a lot of cash and
cash is expensive to handle
it's cumbersome and creates a whole
other boatload of challenges
we need all the services that most
businesses use we just want to operate
like a normal business
the legal cannabis market in the u.s
achieved about 20 billion dollars in
sales in 2020
according to industry analysts that
could grow to over 40 billion annually
by 2025
still most big banks won't work with
cannabis companies because marijuana is
illegal under federal law
and the regional banks or credit unions
that do often
offer minimal services with high fees
but that could change with the safe
banking act which passed the house in
april
if it became law cannabis sales would no
longer be considered illegal
making the banking system accessible to
the cannabis industry
while the bill's fate is uncertain many
in the industry are also encouraged by
the growing number of states legalizing
the drug
and a democratically controlled senate
whose majority leader has voiced support
for broader legalization
in state after state through ballot
initiatives and constitutional
amendments
the american people are sending a clear
message
that they want this policy changed
[Music]
for now these companies face a lot of
restrictions like
limited access to capital and financial
services like credit cards
i'm the ceo of canada provisions we're a
vertically integrated
adult use cannabis company in
massachusetts
with the cultivation and also
manufacturing on the way
we basically accept two forms of payment
one is cash
and one is a debit card sanders
estimates that roughly
40 of transactions at her dispensaries
involve debit cards
that means the company has to deal with
a lot of cash
we have two full-time employees that
just manage our cash
we have to use an armored car service in
order to move our money from our
location to our banks
it's expensive to have this service but
safety is a priority
and this is the safest way to do it
right now
even maintaining a bank account can be
expensive for cannabis businesses
for a typical cannabis operator the cost
for maintaining a bank account can scale
up to about ten thousand dollars a month
nick friedman is cfo of theory wellness
a massachusetts-based company that also
operates in maine
starting theory we didn't have a huge
amount of capital at the time and we
purposely decided to keep it private and
not go
to private equity simply looking to our
own resources
and to friends and family to find the
funds to start the business
we raised about three million dollars
the industry has become much more
sophisticated
we're seeing it now taking hundreds of
thousands if not millions of dollars
to get operational if you only have one
place you can go for
loans or investment capital then they
have the ability to set the terms which
means you're much less likely to get
favorable weight we know businesses that
are paying
20 30 40 interest rates on business
loans
as the cost of participating in this
space has gone up
it has meant that poor and minority
communities
have faced much more of a challenge
trying to get a seed at the table
the challenge with it is you end up
giving
a pretty good chunk of your company away
in order to get your company financed
in massachusetts to open canada
provisions we raised five million
dollars
i would have wished we could have at
least gotten mortgages for our
properties because that would have been
probably a million and a half that i
wouldn't have had to raise
we would expect some pretty
consequential changes to the industry
landscape if federal
banking reform or something equivalent
to it were to pass
the first thing we would expect to see
is the significant drop
in the cost of financing the business
and as a result
we would expect to see a lot more
entrepreneurs start exploring
opportunities
in the space
i think one implication would simply be
the refinancing of some of our debt
which is
at interest rates that i would say is
less reflective of the risk state of our
business but simply more reflective of
the
limited supply of capital that exists
out there thank you
we still have to borrow at interest
rates that are extremely high
we are doing very well and any bank
that i went to with our numbers and our
balance sheet and our p
l would say how much do you want and how
quickly can i give it to you
i can't do that right now you should be
able to build on your success not only
as a company but also with your bank and
financial institutions to make sure that
you can keep growing as fast as the
market needs you to
and i think that's a big hindrance to us